what does it mean for you to know you've
been part of it since season one
and you're into season 14. it's
incredible to be able to
play a character that has such longevity
because a lot of actors
they play a role that lasts you know one
two three seasons
yeah i remember you when you were just a
little guy
[Music]
now look at you all grown up
this character i've been playing ever
since i was a teenager
and so it's followed me through all of
my 20s i'm now in my 30s
and here's a character that has actually
been allowed
to grow and i think that that's
something that is very uncommon in the
world of television
and it's very rewarding for a viewing
audience to be able to be there and and
to see
all of those moments of transition
and in season 14 amber's character amy
fleming
goes through a major moment of
transition as she mourns the loss of her
husband
he's gone grandpa
and he's not coming back what will
happen after
ty's death how is she going to be coping
this season is
a complete emotional roller coaster for
not only the heartland members and
family members but for the viewers
i think throughout this season it's very
important for my character
to recognize that she is the support
system for her daughter
because not only has she lost someone
but her daughter has lost
her father we see amy you know treading
that fine line of
her own personal um loss
and grief and all of these questions
that she has you know
why was he taken so young she has to
put aside and say i need to be there for
my daughter
this show's not only celebrating canada
but around the world it's a show that a
lot of people
really enjoy what is it about heartland
that really speaks to the viewers
the heartland dynamic is something that
a lot of people
wish they had you know the heartland
family is a very traditional family
where we all sit down together for
dinner
it's a multi-generational household and
i actually do believe that
this year this crazy strange year that
we have had
a lot of people have realized that
that's something that they do want to
get back to